nosotros Comencemos por hablar sobre
cómo protege los matrimonios
igualitarios e interraciales esta ley si
no los hace legales en los estados donde
ahora no lo son
estamos teniendo problemas con su audio
todavía no la estamos escuchando por
favor repítanos de nuevo a ver si ya
logramos la conexión
Disculpen
la ley importante porque el hecho de que
todos los estados tengan que respetar
nuestro matrimonio nos da una protección
que va mucho más allá de lo que teníamos
hace poco hasta hace poco Por ejemplo yo
hace diez años que casé en Nueva York y
fue quizás el día más alegre de mi vida
hasta que llegué en el avión de regreso
a Miami porque tenía muy claro que el
avión dejar de tocar la pista en Nueva
York mi matrimonio quedaba anulado o
prácticamente ignorado perdía mis
derechos Entonces eso es algo que ya no
debe pasar en El Siglo 21 y con esta ley
a pesar de que tiene ciertas excepciones
que podemos no estar de acuerdo con ella
nos da un caso muy importante para la
protección general en Estados Unidos qué
bueno que como todos sabemos es un
conjunto de estados que es una situación
complicada a veces manejemos derechos de
igualdad de la comunidad
bueno y avanzan los derechos sexuales en
Estados Unidos mientras retroceden los
derechos reproductivos explíquenos por
favor Por qué se logró este acuerdo
bipartidista mientras los republicanos
siguen hundiendo la protección al aborto
Bueno yo creo que justamente volvemos al
mismo tema es una situación muy
complicada en Estados Unidos sin duda
alguna la extrema derecha cristiana
tiene mucho peso en la decisión de
muchos congresistas ejerce mucha presión
y en el caso digamos de los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres como que
hay menos personas que que puedan
defenderlos en el piso en el en el caso
de la comunidad gay transgénero
afortunadamente hoy en día tenemos
muchas personas que hay transgéneros ya
como servidores públicos y yo creo que
ese empuje nos está ayudando Igualmente
no olvidemos que más o menos un setenta
y cinco por ciento de la población
católica o cristiana apoya al patrimonio
igualitario pero lamentablemente es
mucho menor la incidencia o el
porcentaje de gente dentro de estas
organizaciones religiosas que apoyan al
al aborto